hi
in this uh covid period in lockdown
perhaps like many others so we're
reflecting on the past
us old timers who have been around a
long time doing aikido
and before i start what i want to talk
about
i was i was thinking back of when i was
a
a very young man i started when i was 23
at aikido
i used to drive to london once i become
orange belt
because there was a dojo there called
the hut
it was at the back of a pub in
hillingdon in london
and that's where i had judo boxing
didn't have boxing or judah when i was
there but before the aikido was
a full-time club
and i was just reflecting back about
how we meet friends in life
many of us won't go to a sport
and activity unless our friends go with
us or
they suggest to us we suggest to them
and then you go but
one of you don't stick at it for some
reason
there's always an excuse perhaps an
excuse is a bad thing to say
perhaps it's just it's not for us
we we work it out and we find that it's
not fast but aikido did
turn me on and nearly 50 years on it
still turning me on quite amazing what
we get out of it really
anyway i would travel there
every sunday it doesn't matter what the
weather was
we used to drive me and my friend
and if he couldn't make it i would drive
on my own
because that was the place to train
they were the best in england at the
time
because there was very very few clubs
it was the mecca to me of all dojos
and you you meet new people you start
training with different people and
and once you find somebody who's either
compatible
or you think
uh i've trained this person because
they're really good
and i want to be as good you might even
think i am as good
our egos are on full alert
when we're when we're young i think
and i met one particular person he he
trained and trained
all the time
and uh one winter's day
i went up there and it and it's a big
wooden building it's called the hut
and it is out but a large old
building that i think the raf and that
used to use them
in world war ii i don't know if it was
their offices or
command posts anyway this one was behind
the
pub perhaps i'll look into it one day to
find out
exactly why it was there
it had a pair of doors opened into the
garden
and i think like all of us like it has
to be fun
has to be joyful enjoy what we're doing
and most of the time in my archedon
early days i love doing the techniques
but more importantly i love having fun i
like winning
but if the other person was good as well
i i really enjoyed taking new chemi as
well
but i made it pretty hard for them i was
just stubborn so and so
it had to work or i wouldn't go down
and yeah one day i got the devilman in
me
it was icy outside and really cold in
the dojo
heaters were non-existent you just had
to warm the body and
and man up i suppose in those days not
not the luxuries of a nice sports rule
well i'd notice that i always trained in
one particular spot
and we were kneeling down to start the
class and i noticed there was a just a
smear of ice
where the wind had been blowing under
the two
wooden doors from the garden
and i saw this slither of ice and i
thought to myself
i know what i do i'll play a trick on my
friend
so i i asked mr foster who was
essentially then
my eye opened the doors he looked a
little strange
being such a cold day but he knew how
hard we trained
and so he allowed us to do it i opened
the doors
and as we trained at the appropriate
moment
i threw my friend he hit the ice
he slid and he ejected
outside onto the grass
mr foster looked and said what's wrong
with that boy
and i will always remember that to this
day
never told anybody you're hearing it now
but you see i scheme that because
to have fun because that's what i could
i should be
when it stops becoming fun perhaps we
need a break
don't just stop but perhaps have a break
think about what you do want out of life
what you want out of your aikido life
so i spotted the ice and the detail
on the map and no one else did
my friend was sitting next to me i knew
i was going to be training with him
because we had so much fun together we
trained a lot
or should i say beat each other up a lot
but i spotted these the film of ice on
the mats
and i prepared tactfully
so that's really a technique in itself
to check the ground around you since you
would say
when you're in front of your opponent i
checked the ground
i saw the ice i waited for the
appropriate moment
through him in the appropriate technique
knew that he would be on his back it
slid him into the garden
i had a good laugh he perhaps not so
much a good laugh
an eye for detail and that's what this
particular
film is about traveling around the world
following cytoscency even in the early
days
there would be anything from
i'm going to guess minimum of 80
upwards sometimes hundreds of people on
the seminars
we would talk about it afterwards and
say how does sensi
see someone quite at the back or in the
middle of the pack
how does he see someone out of all those
people
and shouts at them telling him they're
doing it wrong
how do you notice these things
well i now know years on but the time
we didn't if you're a
fifth q or fifth dan listening to this
we all have eyes
we start with the eyes hopefully it
becomes
even more developed and becomes senses
so you sense things
but for the moment i'd like to just show
you a small experiment
of the eyes i'm i've placed
these cocktail sticks
just in my hand here let's just open
that gap up so you don't think there's a
trick
okay now can you see
any difference
if you look closely of course you will
see a difference
because there's one that i've made
different to the others
we never dare our scentsy
how he spotted them how
why would he pick one student out of
let's just say even 80
the minimum amount of people how would
you pick them out
i shout at them telling them they're
doing it wrong
well now i know i don't need to ask
as you've just seen with the cocktail
sticks
if the picture is wrong it doesn't need
to be a fifth down you can see it with
your own eyes
a normal human being but what you have
to do
is you have to look
and when you look across all the
students
let's say they're performing the same
techniques
when the picture is wrong it jumps to
you
you don't have to search for that
so when the picture is wrong
and you spot it that's the time to
correct that person
now many people they don't like being
corrected
if a fifth cue tells a fifth cue how to
do their technique
the fifth q will think well they're the
same grade as me
and object
the when i was a third dan
i was asked to take the class
by a fifth down i've just been on one of
the
senses psychosensitive seminars and i
was asked to
demonstrate when we went afterwards in
the
changing room the third down
a third down said to me what do you
think you're doing telling me what to do
you're only a third down as well
you see i wasn't trying to be whole when
i was trying to say but the picture's
wrong
but people think that you're you're
possibly arrogant when you say the
picture's wrong
they don't like to be told none of us
like to be told
so videoing yourself occasionally
at the moment is mainly weapons you
perhaps can do
chemi exercises
shadow techniques
but video yourself once or twice a year
is my recommendation
and look at yourself don't look blindly
tell yourself um that looks wrong
you will actually sense it as well as
said
but if you deny it perhaps you will deny
it
or your aikido career
thank you for listening i hope this
information's
helpful and please subscribe to my
channel
if you're enjoying the films thank you